eight identical copies of the king james  bible were selected for experimentation  the first copy was placed in the machine  on the setting course the upward  produced was one sheet of leather a  small block of wood a stack of rags  stained with ink and a reel of thread  one to one produced one copy of the  quran on find the output was a book with  lead pages and a golden cover written in  an unidentified language on one to one  it produced a copy of the satanic bible  on very fine the output was a book with  seemingly infinite pages currently at a  page count of 2 million encompassing  religious texts from all known faiths in  all known languages as well as some  religions that have previously never  been seen before